did you know that I'll be back wasn't
actually what that line was supposed to
be let's take a trip down memory lane
and dig up the dirt behind the scenes
secrets from Arnold's biggest films and
there are plenty more secrets where that
came from including Arnold's personal
favorite of his movies spoiler alert
it's definitely not the one you think
allow me to break the ice most of us
agree that the Terminator was Arnold
Schwarzenegger's most iconic role
interestingly though the role almost
wasn't his Schwarzenegger was actually
brought in to play Kyle Reese the
Terminator was set to be played by none
other than O.J Simpson according to
Schwarzenegger director James Cameron
felt that Simpson was not as believable
for a killing machine yep the irony is
lost on no one and apparently there's
even concept art that shows the
characters as O.J Simpson in fact
Schwarzenegger actually has a Terminator
painting that Cameron created himself
and Simpson's face which was painted
over with his own pretty crazy alternate
universe stuff despite his iconic
character status the Terminator is a man
of few words that's under a hundred
words actually in the first film he
speaks only 17 lines to be exact 45 long
slide with laser siding I'm a friend of
Sierra Khana nice night for a walk even
so we all know the one that made him
famous I'll be back this line has some
interesting history it was originally
written as all come back and while this
line has the same exact meaning it's
somehow far less threatening than the
line we know and love furthermore
Schwarzenegger admitted in an interview
that he wanted this line changed to I
will be back since he struggled to
pronounce Isle Cameron said no and
reassured Schwarzenegger that they could
do as many takes as necessary to get a
good one suffice to say they did
audiences first heard the law in 1984
when the movie premiered earning
78.48 million at the box office this
number doesn't land the film in
Schwarzenegger's top 10 highest grossing
films but it's got a hundred percent on
Rotten Tomatoes so it has to be at the
top of our list plus it did pave the way
for some of his films that did rack up
the most at the box office
like Terminator 2 Judgment Day this
movie premiered in 1991. seven years
following the original we know what
we're all wondering most about the
behind the scenes from this movie so
let's get it out of the way quickly no
Schwarzenegger was not actually naked in
that opening scene in fact far from it
he was wearing a colorful pair of shorts
according to director James Cameron he
walked in wearing the loudest pair of
Hawaiian print board shorts that he can
the Wardrobe choice left everyone in the
room looking down in Surprise who would
have thought that's what they were
really looking at if you saw this movie
you likely remember the ending just as
well as you remember that intro remember
how hot the scene looks well it actually
wasn't hot at all in fact it was in the
40s when they were filming so how did
they make it look hot fake spray-on
sweat yep movie Magic is amazing and
this movie was chock full of it from a
miniature City and people that were
created to get blown up to show them
clear explosion to life-size replicas of
Schwarzenegger and co-star Linda
Hamilton that they proceeded to destroy
yikes all the destroyed replicas were
totally worth it though since this film
scored a whopping
519.8 million at the box office and a 91
on Rotten Tomatoes now Terminator 3 rise
of the Machines didn't do quite so well
in terms of its Rotten Tomato score it
only scored a 69 it still managed to
earn a whopping 433.4 million at the box
office though luckily that made it so
the Staggering
29.25 million Arnold Schwarzenegger was
paid to return for the film in 2003 over
a decade after Terminator 2 wasn't too
high a price that said his contract also
included an extra 1.5 million allocated
to a laundry list of perks including
bodyguards a gym hotel suites private
jets and limos to be a major movie star
I love it despite the fact James Cameron
didn't return for this film like the
past Terminator movies Terminator 3 rise
of the Machines worked with lots of
practical special effects the T1 robots
were all actual robots that weighed a
ton each and were built specifically for
the film a team of five puppeteers who
worked off screen were used to operate
each one of the three robots most of us
remember that Terminator Genesis didn't
Premiere until 2015 and you may also
recall that it wasn't exactly as beloved
as the films that came before it it
scored a measly 26 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes still while it didn't reach the
scores of the previous films it earned
almost exactly as much as the box office
as Terminator 3. rise of the Machines
with 432 million Schwarzenegger was 67
years old when Terminator Genesis
premiered and if you're wondering how he
managed to look just as buff as he had
for the previous films well he had it
down to an exact science for six months
he worked out for three hours a day and
by the time they started shooting his
weight measurement were exactly the same
as they had been while shooting
Terminator 3. he still has someone else
playing his younger self though
bodybuilder Brett Azar and now on to
something a little more kid-friendly
Kindergarten Cop this Beloved movie
premiered in 1990 and despite what a
departure it was from Schwarzenegger's
other roles he called it his favorite oh
which is your favorite film of your own
I think Kindergarten Cop probably we can
see why though this movie looks like it
was a ton of fun and some other
a-listers must have predicted how much
fun it would be Schwarzenegger was in
very good albeit surprising company when
going for the role Robin Williams Kurt
Russell and Chuck Norris were also in
the running to play detective John
Kimball once Schwarzenegger landed the
role he put more of himself into the
film than many of us really realize the
star had a list of themes he wanted the
film to touch on for him to agree to be
involved from bringing light to the
importance of physical education to more
challenging themes it's clear that
schwarzania influence bettered the movie
it earned
201.9 million at the box office and 53
on Rotten Tomatoes Total Recall also
premiered in the 1990s but these movies
are very very different Patrick Swayze
was the original lead for the action
flick but when production was canceled
Schwarzenegger was the one who convinced
the new production company to pick it up
it also happened to be one of the last
major movies to use Miniatures rather
than CGI this might be why it was the
second most expensive film ever made at
the time still it managed to score
261.3 million at the box office and an
82 percent on Rotten Tomatoes end of
days came out nearly a decade later in
1999 and while it did fairly well at the
box office with 211.9 million it didn't
do nearly as well with its Rotten
Tomatoes score earning only 11 yes end
of days was not a fan favorite of
Schwarzenegger's films but it did Mark A
New Beginning for the star it was his
first film in two years after having
heart surgery following his role as Mr
Freeze in Batman and Robin Studios have
been worried about his health too much
to cast him but end of days proved his
health was back on track as for Batman
and Robin this film premiered in 1997
and earned
238.2 million it was pretty heavily
disliked scoring only 12 percent on
Rotten Tomatoes still despite the Flop
about which the film star George Clooney
later said I think we just killed the
series Schwarzenegger kept it cool
literally this time as Mr Freeze he
delivered 27 ice puns over the course of
the movie all right everyone Joe please
we are stay cool what killed the
dinosaurs that is the Iceman Cometh cool
party as for a movie that we assume has
zero ice puns don't fact check that
there is that scene about the ice cube
trays after all True Lies premiered in
1994. it earned 379 million at the Box
office and a 70 Rotten Tomato score but
it almost earned something much much
less Pleasant Schwarzenegger's and
during the horse riding scene the star
was in an accident that nearly ended
very badly the horse he was riding
became out of control after something
spooked it Schwarzenegger slid off the
horse next to a 30-foot ledge luckily
his stunt man saved him sounds like
something straight out of one of his
movies eraser premiered two years later
in 1996 and earned
242.3 million and scored 42 on Rotten
Tomatoes the role was first offered to
Sylvester Stallone but he turned it down
since he allegedly heavily disliked the
script well this wasn't an issue for
Schwarzenegger though for whom the team
made multiple rewrites still many folks
consider this film to be the ending of
Schwarzenegger's beloved action era so
what do you think did you agree with the
ranking or did the box office get it all
wrong let us know in the comments and
for more videos like this one be sure to
like And subscribe to the things